Hedrington:
My name's Ben Hedrington.
I work for Best Buy
in the web development space.
I build lots
of different applications,
and a lot of times I like
to prototype things
and get ideas
out there visually.
So what I've done is I've built
a few applications
on App Engine
that help visualize
social media for Best Buy
and for others,
allowing you to see
the different trends
or the people that are
talking about you.
As well as I built
another application
that takes a lot of the voices
of Best Buy associates
and brings them together
on Twitter.
Those two apps are called
Spy and ConnecTweet.
And for me App Engine's
just about speed to market,
getting things out there,
trying things,
testing things,
succeeding or failing.
So that's what I do,
use App Engine to get out
there really fast,
try something,
and see where it ends up.
man: So you mentioned
that App Engine--
you chose App Engine.
Were there any specific
aspects of App Engine
that affected that decision?
Hedrington: Yeah.
As far as what affected
my decision to use App Engine,
it was the instantaneousness
of App Engine that--
You know, there--
I didn't need
to go get a server.
I know how to provision
a server.
I know how to build a server.
That's not needed anymore,
right?
It's not--it's not--
The creativity part of it is
what I wanted to get out there.
I wanted to build something
that you could see.
So, you know, having
to spin up a server,
install software,
manage software,
you know, make sure
that everything
was staying up and staying,
you know, well-positioned,
it didn't make sense
for what I was doing.
And the things I learned
about App Engine
once I started using it was it
kind of lended me towards
building in a scalable manner.
I had to learn Python
at the time,
which was fine.
I love Python now.
And because of the way
App Engine's created,
you have to follow
some design patterns
that lend towards scalability,
and I think that
that's helped going forward
as the app's been picked up
more and more,
that I didn't have
to go rebuild things
or redo things.
It kind of just lives
on its own out there,
open for use.
man: Do you have any
kind of interesting war stories
about developing
on App Engine?
Hedrington:
Um, I don't--
I don't think I have
any interesting war stories,
but I think any developer
who does kind of prototyping
and quicker stuff
always dreads
when they need to show that
to somebody.
Or another for instance,
the one app I have called Spy,
it actually runs
in a lot of the C level
executives' offices at Best Buy.
They full screen it
on a monitor,
and it just kind
of ticks through
the different social things
being said about Best Buy.
And that's one of those things
that's like,
it's something I built quick,
and it wouldn't really
hurt my credibility too much
if it stopped working,
but it would make me feel bad
as a developer, right?
That I've got something
sitting in an executive's office
that's not working.
And I think App Engine has
satisfied a lot of that to me.
You know, the infrastructure's
always up.
As long as my code's
relatively solid,
it's just gonna
keep running and ticking.
I mean, the interesting thing
about the app
is it's a real-time app,
so it's constantly updating.
And, you know,
it'll sit and run
on that computer
in their office
for months at a time.
And I think
that that's nice.
You know, it lets you
sit back a little bit
and not be worried you got to
sneak in their office
and refresh the machine
if it breaks
or anything like that.
So that would be
one for me,
just that confidence factor
when you're gonna
go demo something
that you threw together
relatively quickly
that it'll still be there,
still running
and still working.
man: Okay, so it has kind of
affected the way
you think about production.
Hedrington: It does.
You know, I'm--
A lot of what I think
that we do
and some of the other folks
that you guys will talk to
from Best Buy,
we try to just
bring new concepts
and visualize them
to people.
So yes,
you can release.
You can release hourly.
You can release daily
if you need to.
You know, it's there.
And the way the web is moving,
it's much, you know, faster
and more iterative.
So, you know,
getting comfortable with that,
with smaller type activities
is good.
So, you know, that's somewhere
that I'm already at.
But I think doing
these type of things
helps others see that.
You know, there is a need
sometimes for, you know,
month-long, year-long
development processes,
but there's also things,
especially in the web space
where you can move
much faster,
deploy to production,
you know,
and really get out there.
man: So do you have, like,
a future wish list
for App Engine?
Hedrington: Yeah.
You know, some of the stuff that
they're already talking about.
A future wish list for me
would be, you know,
the background processing.
One of my apps that
I haven't talked about yet
called ReTweet Radar
pulls a lot of things
from Twitter
and kind of extracts
different concepts from them.
So what it does is it needs
to go do that quite often,
and since there's
no background processing today,
I have to kind of
force that to happen.
So that's a big one for me.
Otherwise, you know,
I'm generally pretty happy.
I would have said
when I started,
"Oh, it'll be nice when you guys
roll out new languages."
But really, for what I've
learned of Python
and what I like about Python,
I'm probably gonna
stick with it.
You know, I didn't go
jump on the Java bandwagon.
I've done it in the past,
and, you know,
maybe I will someday.
But, you know,
I was actually--
I think I talked
about this a lot
when I started
using App Engine--
I was happy about
the constraints of App Engine.
They made me think harder
about what I was trying to do
and how I went
about doing that.
And I appreciate that.
And you can tell there's
some engineering behind that.
So, you know,
that's about all.
man: Well, thanks a lot
for coming in
and talking to us.
Hedrington: All right.
man: all right.